what's up everyone welcome to gamespot
we are here covering san diego comic-con
I'm Mike McCarty here with Justin hey
wall Justin you got the chance to play
sonic mania the newest entry in the
storied sonic franchise they just
announced it last night and and here at
gamma con seems like maybe a weird place
to announce a new sonic game but it's
it's also really exciting because it's
like a revival of the original sonic and
they show that off to really great
effect with the green hill zone like
this iconic very recognizable sonicstage
and the thing I think that they nail the
best besides just like great 2d art that
meant pixelated style is the speed of
sonic that he's going so fast that you
can get going it's such a speed that you
don't even see herself on the screen you
just have to kind of help you know we
were going it's been so long since I
played the game then it for me it was
more luck than anything else and a lot
of running into barriers but that sense
of speed was both so nostalgic and so
funny remind you of what makes sonic
great if I'm not a sonic fan is this
game that's gonna be bringing me back
into the franchise or at all or is this
more for people that just kind of for
whatever reasons want more sonic all the
time you know I people have complained
about sonic for the longest time that
they they want something new or there's
something different or and then when you
get something new and different that
it's not enough of the same and I think
that this is really going to appeal to
the fans who have wanted a core sonic
game this is a 2d adventure that
captures the gameplay the speed and just
that fun of those original sonic games
it remasters a lot of the the levels
that are very recognizable to Sonic fans
we've seen a trend towards this and
other indie games shovel Knight is when
it comes to mind immediately is
something that had a great pics related
art style very old-school gameplay and I
think Sega is really smart to try to
recapture that to rekindle that that
fuel for the traditional the old school
and just the fun so it's a return to
form for the franchise but what is new
did you see anything that stood out from
your brief chunk of the game when they
were talking about it they did say that
some things were new I didn't get to try
it out as much we had a really limited
amount of time and a very short amount
of gameplay they said that the wid
they've tweets the controls that it's
not something that you'll notice if
you're just watching somebody play it
but then it's it's a lot easier to get
up to speed you don't have to only just
stand there they've added a jump
ash ability so that you can start going
really quickly in an intuitive way for
for newcomers rather than just the
extend still start spinning up and going
fast that way so what do you think are
you excited hey I'm excited I've never
been a huge sonic fan but going back to
these original games those are what drew
me in as a kid like that's what I grew
up playing and I would love to get some
more of that what platforms will we be
playing this on and when will it be
releasing I think it's coming out on ps4
xbox one and pc but it's not coming out
till next year so there's a lot of time
this is a very early look at the game
all right well there you have it that's
sonic mania for more news coming out of
San Diego comic-con we here at gamespot
are going to be here for another couple
of days check back in and we'll see you
then gota go fast
you